[Music]
ants scientists have been putting these
social Critters under the microscope for
hundreds of years
but it seems one strange Behavior has
been under their nose the whole time
we've discovered the phenomena that had
never been observed before researchers
spotted a strange fluid coming from amp
pupae and it turned out to be key to the
survival of the whole colony
ants are extremely social creatures each
with a role to play
but then there are the pupae this
immobile stage of the ant life cycle
between larvae and adults don't seem to
do much and have been thought of as kind
of useless
until now we've discovered that a
isolated secret a copious amount
of fluid only snare and her colleagues
noticed the adult ants feeding on this
nutritious fluid secreted by the pupae
and they seemed to boost the colony's
success without it they struggled if we
prevented colonism from pupae and only
gave them a um either nothing or a prey
they exhibit a less Revival and stunted
growth it wasn't just the adult ants
that were consuming this fluid all they
noticed adults going out of their way to
place young larvae on the immobile pupae
and lovely survival seemed dependent on
the fluid I found that the pupil
secretion is rich in nutrients in
hormones and the neuroactive substances
it seems like this fluid plays a
previously unknown yet vital role in the
success of an ant colony
and interestingly Ollie found this
phenomenon in a wide range of different
ant species we're confident that this
actually happens in all other acts the
fact that seems to occur across ants
could mean that this is a characteristic
feature of ants and to only these
findings show that pupae really have
been overlooked think one of the major
implications is to shift our perspective
of how we see the colony from an adult
eccentric
perception into a network perception
this vital fluid contribution from
apparently passive pupae shows that they
are an important part of ants complex
social structures
and are yet another example of how
tightly intertwined and interdependent
the lives of these social insects really
are
[Music]
Mountain